Okay dope it workedWe ain't making a
ternary.
Sorry I'm not 100% sure how you can fit this
inSo instead underneath hero dot help let's
create a.
If true condition so we'll say if
hero.health
Is greater than 100 we're going to use these
double ampersands
And what this is saying is if this condition
to the left is true
Let's go ahead and reassign hero.health to
equal 100
Let's actually wrap this up it's mad at me
cuz I don't have this in the parentheses so
sweet
At this point let's go ahead and we can just
get rid of all this
We can actually add this and here as well
because this is just returning alert to this
point so
At this point we make sure we check that
bull so if hero has potion health or has
health
potion is false we're going to send them
back this alert essentially this is going to
be our air
Now I'm going to do that then we're going to
check to see if the hero health isGreater
than equal to 100.
And then we'll check if it's below zero or
equal and then if all those factors aren't
true let's go ahead and actually
increase the health and set it to 100 if it
is at 100 and then let's draw the health at
that point
Perfect
Oh sorry I stopped meant to stop recording